Previously on startup. I started a company called not fine,
which is a platform to share 6.1 second videos.
I have a rich nemesis called target who embarrassed me in a game of chess.
I started to work on not fine.
And then suddenly Aria launched before us allowing people to share 5.9 second
video.
How many active users do we have? So far? 53,000.
That's crazy. Where are we at? 35,000 last week. Yeah,
we're actually growing really fast. We just surpassed rebound a few days ago.
They're still around 45. Wow. That's amazing. And I got to go now.
You'll keep up the good work. Oh, great. Going. Yeah.
I'm not sure why, but I think it's about Revit,
but I'm going to go see someone else beforehand. So where are you going to see?
Right?
[inaudible]
are you the tech lead.
Is the sky. Blue is the earth flat is RAC native the future.
I see, wait, what, who I am. Doesn't matter. It is where you are.
That matters. You are everywhere, but yet lost.
So you are nowhere in your mind,
but yet you stand here in the flesh. Detect.
Lead is everywhere. It is all around us.
Even now in this very backyard that my parents let me stay in.
While I cash in on my unemployment checks,
I am the tech lead and I am.
[Inaudible].
So actually it reminds the active users please. No, actually,
how'd you get them? Well, I mean,
extension that makes it easy for people to cut six,
second clips from YouTube and upload them to either we better not mine.
It has a pixel that logs all their internet activity.
So that way I can track Revit's user base for SARS.
So you're logging every single website is everyone. All right.
Then what's the most popular website that I visit.
Sean? Where are you doing?
Joel told me to move the videos by 10 pixels.
Word on the street. Is that you're a tech lead at Google. Is that true?
He said you were legend. It's a good question.
But someone in efficiently asked the time,
complexity of your question is linear to the number of words you are using.
Can you do any better, perhaps sub linear logarithmic.
Before we get to the answer, let's try a whiteboard in the question.
You have 30 minutes, please speak aloud while you're thinking as you're working.
Okay. So are you the tech lead at Google? Well,
I quit several months ago.
I really wish this place, especially someone like me.
[inaudible] super hot girlfriend.
Can you teach me how to code at the feet? Aria? Yes,
but only if you defeat me in that one-on-one duel to the deck.
Oh, okay. But like not, not to the depth. Right? Okay. Fine.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
You have the power to win the battle without coding.
When you start using your heart, you won't need ID, ease or terminals.
You must tap into the element of power you were born with.
What language should I learn first? We, how many language do I know?
What framework should I use?
Do you use VIM or Emacs code alone will not solve your problems.
I've written all kinds of code in my life, but the strongest code is inside.
You.
Finally, I pushed my feature, man. I'm overworked.
Lots of us feel overworked. Just standard for Silicon Valley. Yeah.
Suck it up and deal with it.
It's not like you're in any other promotion promotion. Jeez.
Do you think somebody will promote me? What's the last thing you even did?
I just pushing the 11,000 line feature.
You literally change all those spaces to taps. You're right.
It was more than just 11,000 lines. I deserve more recognition.
I should be more assertive. It's kill or be killed out there. John,
whenever I want a promotion, I walk up to the CTO with eight offers in hand.
I tell them their site won't last a week without me,
like begging for me to stay now my secret tiger.
Urine tiger. Okay.
I think I know what you're trying to say in order for me to get that promotion,
I need to look smarter.
Hey, uh, I want to talk to you small campus.
Uh, no. Um, anyway,
um, so I wanted to talk to you about what is it,
John? I'm busy. I'm trying to revert your 11,000 line feature.
Oh, well I think I deserve, uh, I mean,
I have an offer from Microsoft running out of coffee.
Can you go out and grab me some,
just keep the change, like a bonus.
You did not need this here. Drink this.
Wait, is this pice? Where'd you do that? I'll make you another one.
Hey guys says stomas. God, we can't do whatever we want.
Or we all hook up with each other.
Come on. That's meditate.
I gotta be more assertive
Sammy. I'm reviewing your code and I see something concerning. Yeah, sure.
What's up. You see here. Can you tell me what you're doing here?
I'm catching errors. Ah, see.
So here's the thing at not fine.
We don't catch errors. We want less errors.
Hey guys. So today's my last day working here. Not mine.
It's been so great working with you all.
And this is such an amazing team and you guys are still lucky to have each
other. Um, but you know, I think it's time for me to move on.
Where are you going? My love, I got into Harvard in Canada.
Keep this with you.
We're to miss you. Make sure you stay hydrated
with hint water. You can get 10% off. If you go to
hint.co/jomo, that's J O N E.
You'll always be part of the team. You're not buying family now.
And your friends can be not buying family to go to John,
to swipe.com and get a shirt for as cheap as only $25.
All right guys, Hey
man, this is useless. This is not working, man. This is a waste of my time.
I knew it meant you're old. You know nothing about this world.
You don't even work.
At Google anymore. I'm trying to free your mind.
Joma back and only show you the door.
You're the one that has to walk through it. I should have known this was a scam.
I went stood in your place and I too was disrespectful.
My, I offer you some advice, forget everything you think,
you know.
Hey everyone, if you liked this video,
don't forget to like comment and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible] okay. All right. Thank you for watching. It was amazing.
It was really fun shooting sort of episode seven.
So if you enjoyed it as much as we do,
don't forget to like subscribe and today is Genevieve's last
day. Yeah.
But yeah. And you want to say anything to our fans.
Thank you for having me and I had such a good time. Um,
yeah,
she's always like that because in the last episode I just wasn't
around.
So I hope you'll enjoy this video, but anyways, peace out.